how do climate scientists use ice as a
time machine every year in the polar
region snow falls more Falls in Winter
than in summer and the ice crystals are
different siid so we can tell the
difference between winter and summer
snowfall as year after year of snow
builds up it gets compressed by the
weight of snow above into ice if we
drill a core from an ice sheet we can
see distinct layers of snowfall and by
counting the number of winter layers
down from the surface we can find out
how old a particular layer is like rings
on a tree that's really useful because
trapped in those layers of ice are tiny
samples of the atmosphere as it was when
the snow fell scientists can measure the
composition of air in these bubbles to
recreate for example what CO2 levels
were like in the past but they can also
recreate what the global average
temperature was in the past when the
Earth's average temperature is cooler
less oxygen 18 which is a heavy isotope
of oxygen makes its way into Polar Ice
so by measuring the relative amount of
oxygen 18 in these different ice layers
scientists can estimate how temperatures
in the past changed and when